le panier anti-inflation proposé dans ce
magasin est affiché fièrement dans les
allées ou dans les rayons et attire
l’œil des clients vous avez bien sûr de
la lessive pour le linge puis vous allez
avoir des produits du petit déjeuner
vous allez avoir des conserves de
légumes vous allez avoir de l'huile de
la sauce tomate un choix de produit du
quotidien dit essentiel qui déçoit
pourtant certains consommateurs
légumes choses comme ça j'ai pas trouvé
ces opérations anti-inflation vont durer
jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin
alors déjà qui autour de la table à
ressenti l'inflation réellement
je les fais toutes les semaines j'ai un
enfant donc je fais un plan de course
une fois par semaine il y a un truc qui
m'a choqué et j'étais avec mon fils et
on achète donc du papier toilette c'est
quand même voilà ce qu'on achète tous il
était à 6 euros le le rouleau non pas le
mettre ciseaux les les quatre les quatre
rouleaux de papier toilette franchement
j'ai été choqué je ne l'ai même pas
acheté mon fils il m'a dit mais on va
faire comment je vais en Valais ailleurs
parce que franchement j'achète pas du
papier toilette à 6 euros je trouve ça
abusé et moi personnellement quand j'ai
fait les courses la semaine dernière
vu de panier inflation je sais pas si
c'est vraiment partout en tout cas dans
le supermarché où j'étais il y en avait
pas dans la périphérie de Paris alors
j'ai qu'est-ce que l'inflation qu'on
comprenne bien qu'on parle de natation
mais c'est quoi en fait c'est une
augmentation des prix qui est souvent
qui était presque étal pendant des
années et qu'il a brutalement nous fait
peur parce que on voit 6% c'est à dire
que les prix vont augmenter de % et les
indices à la consommation sont calculés
sur un ensemble de prix le problème
c'est qu'il y a pas tout dedans vous
avez par exemple l'électronique qui va
baisser mais l'électronique
or le problème d'aujourd'hui c'est que
l'inflation sur les produits de la vie
quotidienne les produits alimentaires
tout ce qui est viande fruits et légumes
produits laitiers etc les produits du
quotidien explosent on va jusqu'à des
vins voyez viande surgelées 30% donc les
prix augmentent tellement que le votre
panier votre caddie quand vous allez
votre chariot quand vous allez au
supermarché devient délirant ce que vous
payez par exemple 60 euros ça devient un
casier à 90 euros et les gens ne peuvent
plus maintenant
les prix augmentent et ce que vous avez
pris la fonction c'est la différence
si les salaires augmentaient de 20%, il
y aurait pas d'inflation tu nous poses
après une augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat c'est que les prix plus jamais
ne baisseront là on est à plus 6% sur un
an les experts estiment l'augmentation a
jusqu'à 15% durant l'année 2023 alors
ils ont lancé une baisse de l'inflation
d'ici 3 mois quand même ah oui
c'est un printemps rouge mais c'est pas
du gouvernement annoncé une amélioration
doit être donc pour améliorer tout ça il
y a ce panier anti-inflation qui fait
polémique et notamment je crois le le
panier de chez u
c'est là où j'étais
et ben il y avait pas le panier
d'inflation quand je suis allé
en place Edward c'est moins cher j'ai
pas dit la marque non non on a pas dit
la marque alors on va c'était Auchan
aussi comme ça ce sera fait et puis
Auchan et lui il a refusé le panier
anti-inflation parce que les prix je
vais faire moi je fais les courses
en caisse à compter le prix à chaque
fois j'adore c'est un jeu j'essaie de
trouver exactement vraiment ça
augmentait mais je vous promets moi
quand je fais des courses mais j'ai pas
été tant sur que ça du moins là-bas
c'est régulier je fais toujours le même
qu'a dit ça augmenter un peu mais c'est
pas catin c'est pas kata sur un caddie à
110 c'est monté à 100 c'est monté à 110
112 sur le même panier tour ce que je
fais alors il y a les les produits qui
ont fait polémique hein dans ce panier
de chez u donc c'est des cacahuètes des
chips huit bouteilles d'alcool
du pastis notamment du rhum du whisky
ce qui est triste et qu'on se bat pour
dire justement faites attention à ce que
vous mangez il y a de l'obésité il y a
plein de choses et ça joue pas le jeu de
l'autre côté en disant voilà on va faire
un panier anti inflation avec des
produits entre guillemets sert c'est ça
qui est dommage le panier ne reflète pas
les besoins exacts du
consommateurs
comme tout le monde
je suis pas faux-cul comme vous on boit
pas mon chien mange des légumes
je prends du McDo je prends je prends un
petit pastille je mange des frites voilà
comme tout le monde d'accord très bien
merci pour cette remarque alors la
réponse de ce magasin de ce grand
magasin nous avons essayé de proposer
une gamme large même si on peut toujours
trouver matière assez interrogée
proposer des fruits et légumes frais et
entre complexes à mettre en place car
leurs achats n'est pas centralisé voilà
donc mais gérer localement par les
magasins ce qu'il y a aussi c'est qu'en
fait il y a beaucoup il y a des marques
qu'on connaît tous et puis à la marque
du distributeur et en fait dans les
paniers inflation il y a beaucoup ces
marques de distributeur et c'est pas
forcément la moins chère donc il faut
vraiment quand même faire attention
parce que c'est un petit peu aussi un
coup de com donc soyez vigilants
qui ont beaucoup augmenté et les couches
confiance aussi
comme un effort il y a un effort
c'est une catastrophe
sucre sucre
c'est pas pour aider les gens ça c'est
le problème c'est que le gouvernement en
fait c'est défaussé sur les les magasins
de grande distribution pour faire
quelque chose alors qu'en fait c'était
au gouvernement peut-être de prendre une
mesure comme l'autre fois il y avait
Éric Revel qui parlait de la TVA à 0 %
ou en tout cas baisser la TVA sur les
produits de première nécessité qui
donnerait un panel plus large de choix
aux gens et surtout sur des produits
frais sain que tu disais le PQ les
produits essentiels
notamment sur tout ce qui produit de
promesses de dentifrice c'est une veste
catastrophe produit d'hygiène
catastrophique